We choose not to talk a lot about diversity
and inclusion.
We’re not running from the topic.
We actually feel like we’re addressing it
head on using analytics and revenue and profit
to drive the conversation versus some moral
imperative.
And what that means is that it’s not about
fairness and equality alone, it’s about
equity, which is about people getting – if
you treat someone as a person they need a
little more of something than perhaps someone
else.
And actually if you treat everyone the same
you are not going to get the best out of everyone.
So equality can be used, in fact, to exclude
people and to make the environment a place
that certain groups of people don’t want
to be in because you’re treating everyone
the same.
That’s just not the way humans work.
You know, I have two kids.
One of them might need (when they were young)
violin lessons.
Another one might need dental care.
Well the dental care costs a lot more than
the violin lessons, but they both got something
that they needed but it wasn’t necessarily
ever equal.
But it’s addressing people where they are.
We also find that diversity and inclusion,
once you bring up those words tension goes
up in the room, because what happens is when
you say that what people think is race but
they don’t want to talk about it because
they don’t know how to talk about that.
So they awkwardly talk about diversity and
inclusion and the problem that needs to be
addressed gets diluted.
We begin to talk about – we can’t talk
about race so then we just say “people of
color” and “people majority” because
we can’t say “race”.
And then we talk about men and women because
that’s easier than race.
And then what about the disabled?
“Oh well we can’t really bring that up.”
And all these buttons go off that stops the
conversation.
What we pursue is called a Great Place to
Work For All.
That’s the way we do it.
So we think every employee regardless of who
they are, what they are, or what they do for
the organization should have a great experience
at work.
So that includes everyone.
It does not separate anyone to say, “One
group should have a really great experience
and one can have a less great experience.”
It means all.
It turns into something positive, and people
then get engaged and they go, “Yeah, it
should be a great place to work for me too.
Absolutely.
For everybody here, so let’s talk about
how to do that.”
And you find the whole room starts to lean
forward.
Rather than “the other topic”, people
can’t wait to get out of the room.
And talking about the other topic for, you
know, I heard that conversation for about
40 years.
It hasn’t gotten us very far at all.
What we should want is for everybody to be
like it is at the top of an organization.
Excited about coming to work and doing something
that you really, really care about.
You’re paying for it.
It doesn’t cost you any more money, so you’re
just getting more for what you’re paying
for.
Most businesspeople get that.
They get it and they go okay, what’s getting
in the way?
And we have the analytics to help them know
what’s getting in the way.
It’s the way they’re being spoken to gets
in the way.
It’s if you’re listening to them or not,
you know.
Are you sincerely caring about what they’re
saying and using it to innovate and to make
business decisions?
We asked, “Does management involve you in
their decision making?
Do you feel informed about how management
makes decisions?”
The reason we ask these is so we can understand
what a person is experiencing, and we know
a certain type of experience that makes people
say, “I love it here,” because we asked
“Do you plan to work here for a long long
time?” and people will say yes.
And you can predict it based on whether people
are listening to them, whether people are
welcoming them, whether people are rewarding
them, whether people are recognizing them,
whether people address them personally rather
than an employee in mass communications.
You can actually predict these two things,
and then you see it in the result of the company
in terms of the employee experience the number
is very high, and we’ve proven that the
revenue growth of the company, we have a hunch
it’s going to be higher than others, and
we look at the data and, in fact, that is
true.